So how do you do this? Well, I'm pretty
lazy and my first reaction is always to try
to avoid the issue if possible. Remember, anything that
the browser is responsible for rasterizing it can probably do
at the native resolution of the screen. So if
you can effectively use vector graphics like scalable vector
graphics, or canvas to draw your graphics, You absolutely
should. Although I do want to note that by default,
canvas has a backing store set to a 1x
pixel density. That is, it won't rasterize in higher
resolution on 2x or 3x displays. You can change
it and get a higher resolution backing store by setting
the width and height on the canvas to the
upscale dimensions. Multiply them by device pixel ratio, then scale
your entire context, or use css width and height
to get it to lay out to the appropriate size.
We don't do this automatically in the browser though,
if we did, canvases on two x devices would cost
four times as much memory, and 3 x devices
with cost nine times as much memory. On mobile devices
that might have pretty limited memory to begin with.
Now, for small icons or glyphs, you may wish to
use icon fonts which are a handy way to
get pretty looking icons that scale well. For general prettiness,
using CSS features like gradients, rather than a gradient image is a
radically good idea. And, CSS3 features like rounded corners and boarders. Save
you from having to supply custom graphics for each corner and they
have the added benefit of reducing the number of requests your page makes.